okay so there's I said there were more
right so I've done this summon
difference with sight how am I going to
do the summer difference for college now
again you can prove this in all kinds of
different ways but if I can I want to
use what I already know to get me to
this so what's the relationship between
sine and cosine again like what is the
need tell you okay come it's a continent
okay
so therefore cause of something should
be equal to sine of 90 degrees minus
whatever that something was does that
make sense so sine 30 cos 60 sine 21 cos
you hear whatever adds up tonight so I'm
going to write that over you 90 degrees
minus this angle over here like so okay
now that symmetrical triangle is a
contra de Ville so I'm going to write it
and there's a bunch of different ways
again but I could do this right in the
simplest way I'm just going to expand
this out so I get rid of the brackets
I'm going to have minus alpha minus then
okay now watch like I said there's lots
of prejudice but the simplest way to use
the knowledge I already know or this is
to say why do not to do it three angles
I only know what to do with two so I'm
just going to lump a couple of them
together as one able how about this pair
I'm going to call my anybody alpha and
recall that one angle watch what happens
have a look have a look at that line
I've just written which one of these do
I need to use this one don't know could
look if the difference is the latest in
between so here's another so I'm going
to write this but instead of these
alphas here what am I going to write my
90 minus Alpha and the beta is fine
right it's a my table on the
okay let's do it so I'm going to write
sine of 90 degree minus alpha
Kamisha this one right cos beta
what's this time in the middle again
okay what's the next thing I write very
good cause of 90 minus alpha and sine
beta
all I've done is just a straight swap
into that using these two okay I'm
almost there
hold on a second good from here to here
I changed cosines and designs by using
this other identity I know one of the
complementary identities right because
they add up to 90 but look now I have
more of these guys flying around what is
sine of 90 minus alpha by definition
it's good that far right it's the
complement see so that causes for you
define the middle is aren't - my-baby
sky that's like oh [ __ ] and hey presto
there's your identity for COS of alpha
plus bigger right slightly weird because
you're like alright you can start to see
I'm reading a lot early and they do look
quite similar to each other don't it
which is why we give you the reference
sheet so that you should start to get to
remember them but if you're unsure like
where is the fossil and is this the one
where slightly closer together
or in this one where carbon clothes are
together okay if you're ever in doubt
we've got that there it's kind of a
safety blanket okay but the more you use
is the more comfortable you get if I've
done closet alpha plus beta what's the
natural next step
yeah do the difference this will be
quicker now that I've already
established all of this - stuff right so
I'm going to substitute into here but
instead of beers I'm going to have
negative videos right so I'm going to
have cos alpha cos of new video p.m. -
sine alpha sine of negative bail we
already know what happens the cause of
negative beat up
right mm what happens yeah the same is
called beta right it doesn't change so I
just got cos alpha con being I still
hang up but there what happens we go yet
okay so this sine of negative beta right
I can rewrite as negative sine beta is
today gives you one here and one here
right so therefore this is plus okay one
two three four five is sine close with
last chance okay now again I will use
all the knowledge I've already developed
on the board
I'm just fitting at there in order to
save me the most like proving it from
scratch make your holy diagram all that
kind of thing so can by definition again
use one a trig identity or Ino is
whatever what sine over cards do you
like I've just stated what tan is okay
they like older I do anything going
science must be is a bit of a mess Colin
a suppose leader is also a mess so the
next time I've got to write be going to
be a little bit gross but stay with it
sine Albert close Venus by the way if
you're wondering how I'm writing me the
order right I tend to do them in order
of angles right so alpha comes
alphabetically first before made up if
this is like P and Q I write PQ here and
then I've got PQ here well you can do
whichever order you like these just the
convention ones sign up because they up
plus cos alpha sine V no divided by cos
alpha cos beta and -
okay now at this point I'm going to
employ a little bit of a trick that
you've learned you've seen before in
doing your trig abilities which is this
is a bit of a mess I can simplify it a
little bit by dividing the top and
bottom by the same theme I just need to
choose the right thing okay now in this
case there is a whole bunch of different
things you can choose in this case what
I'm going to choose is cos alpha cos
beta I do the top I'm going to do the
bottom so you can write actually
changing this I'm just rewriting this
platen for clothes one term at a time
we'll start with the bottom conductor
easier come on down because Vita /
concept because they're good sine alpha
sine beta divided by cos alpha cos V
well yeah the sine alpha code Apple will
match a Siberian Claude B will also
match so that gives you tan alpha and B
do you agree with that so the bottom
looks nice not the top what happens well
I think I'd if I cos alpha cos beta
right this side alpha matches with this
to create tan alpha and then this cos
beta this convener or they just can't
laugh they just or so so that did what
about here what's going to happen here
the cod alphas are just going to cancel
out leaving you with sine beta on cos
beta almost looks so bad after all
okay okay I have one last spot on the
board right here in the middle and I'm
gonna cheat and you so we've done some a
difference for sine we've done the sum
of difference because the last one to
answer the Sun for 10 years
sonofa okay
so now this time to say D because you've
done a lot of legwork Andrea cut
straight to the chase here is the
identity I wonder if you can see why
this is what it has to be
what's change from that one to this one
so it's just the sign again which is a
thing you probably see right
notice this one plus the pump applies is
different - and my look here the plus at
of - turns into a - at a bus here you've
got you've got folks you've got a plus
and a minus here which becomes a minus
or a plus here right what it's ten
strong is this remember how we did all
of this stuff over here trying to again
with the negatives okay well it turns
out you can do this just like you could
with sign all that usual de Graaff and
continuous up with it but that's the
important result that sort of lets you
unlock that and turn into this